[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone so today we'll be talking
about background removal hope you're
excited about it please prepare there
will be a lot of pictures so clean your
eyes let's go so a little bit about me
uh my name is Aran kovka as already
mentioned I have a a degree in computer
science from the University of ltia and
I currently work as a data scientist in
the generative Squad uh and the things
that I'm interested in researching and
working on would be llms of course
computer vision NLP stuff and outside of
work uh when I'm not researching those
wonderful things I also like Fiber Arts
such as crochet and sewing I like hiking
but please do not be full that is not in
lat we live in a very flat country and I
also like cats I have two of my own that
visit my meetings very frequently
colleagues love them I'm sure about it
and today I'm representing printify
which is a print on demand company that
allows people to become entrepreneurs by
creating and selling custom products and
maybe someone here already heard about
print on demand just to understand the
level of the
audience cool so some people but not a
lot so let's give a practical example
just to make it more clear of how you
can actually use uh our platform so
Christmas is coming up let's say you
have a colleague Tom that you're very
friendly with and you know that Tom
loves python he just really loves python
so what better way to show it than with
a custom T-shirt so you go to printify
you put the lovely python image uh on
the T-shirt then you create the product
then you place it as a sample or you
just create an order with it and boom
happy Tom happy python t-shirt maybe not
exactly this one because you know like
background removed and stuff like who
would wear
that I can explain I can explain so this
might be an extreme example but
background removal works in mysterious
ways for example when you're just
getting started you can just not know
that you cannot place a white background
the with a like an image with a white
background on a white T-shirt because it
will be printed quite weirdly and it's
not going to be something you'd expect
you might have run into issues with your
customers or Tom if he is very
particular about his t-shirts or as a
beginner designer you're also not going
to know that semi-transparency can cause
some issues so you might create a very
complex design you'll be very happy
about it but then when you get it sent
it's actually not looking as crisp as
when you saw it on the mockups so you
have to take a lot of the things into
account uh so that's why the background
removal is very important in our
platform and when we realize that this
is a problem that Merchants are actually
uh uh complaining about it they don't
want to like for example if you you get
to offered an image that has a
background you're not really wanting to
include it because you want people to
buy your product obviously so as a
business the first thing we did we
thought okay background removal sounds
quite familiar so there are probably
tools online that have already got it
handled and they're super proper experts
on it right so one of the companies that
we partner up with uh they do some image
enhancement stuff for us uh we talked to
them and they actually had a background
removal uh Tool uh in the works and they
offered us free demo to understand how
it works and we were like super let's
see it and we thought this going going
to be like super great and we were going
to be using it and whatnot but then you
look at it and well not really there you
know uh there are common issues such as
parts of the test can be missing uh
maybe something gets removed where it
shouldn't have been or it's the other
way around you know and uh in this
particular scenario the reasons for this
are quite obvious so uh they were
targeting it towards e-commerce which is
a entire different sphere like if you
want to show something like a product
like a book a photo camera something
else and you wanted to to do a
customized background for it okay yeah
that will work but the designs of the
T-shirt the mugs any other products that
we could sell they are quite particular
in a way and they are not similar to the
product images and as me as measured by
the company themselves the success rate
for this scenario was only 10% we send
them a bunch of images that we could be
that it could be evaluated on and it was
only 10% which is obviously not
something we would want to use and
that's where we thought like fine tuning
could be of help yes but if you think
about it uh they're not really targeting
print on demand companies which we are
only one and if every other company in
the market with their own specific
domain and sphere and data will come to
them it's not going to be much
profitable for them uh so it's not like
were trying to put us as a priority in
finding specifically for us uh so all
right that happens let's go to the other
uh Solutions we we know that there are
some other external tools and how do we
compare them well we definitely want to
know what the inference speed would be
like uh what's the pricing of those
tools and uh the results should be
measured on different type of images
that we have in our system so one of
them would
be the graphic image so something like
you know a human a forest some kind of
object no text then the text alone so it
will be only textual information and
there is a combo of both which is quite
popular if you go on Etsy for example
and search for some I don't know python
t-shirts you're most likely going to
stumble upon a logo than I love python
let's say so uh we measured it on uh we
we did some comparison on other tools
and this is just one of the samples and
you can see that it's definitely better
than we first saw but it's still not
perfect you can see by the arrows that
some elements are still missing uh it's
not critical you can Must In some cases
you can just bring the text back but not
in all cases and this is a very very
small sample so here we thought that
since we have an ml team that we can
experiment that we could do some
research and create a model that is
better than the external Solutions and
look at how the results of the training
our own model will look
like so this kind of task falls under
computer vision umbrella and it's called
Salient object detection and uh
basically what it is it's very human
oriented in the definition such as you
would want to detect what the human eye
catches first so that would be the
background so let's say you have a
person it's it's going to be the first
thing that catches your eye and Forest
will be the background and with all of
the other pictures it's like that as
well so the ground roof for this task
would be an image the original one and
then a black and white mask where black
is the background white is the
foreground so let's go to train our
model but we have no data uh tail is all
this time well not really if you think
about it it's not impossible to create
the data for this tasks so that's what
we did uh this is the very first model
prototype that we had it was a very
quick one uh but basically what we did
is we generated some training data we
took some t-shirt designs and then
manually created the masks for those
images and in the end it was not a big
set it was just 25
images uh like 25 image Pairs and what I
did is actually it was trained in the
local PC so very very small quick test
if it's even if it's even holding up to
the concept of training a model and the
model that we used was the U net a
neural network uh with an encoder
decoder structure and uh let's look at
the results obviously still not great
kind of looking more than like the first
result than the external one that was
commercially available so I I understand
why it's better but still if you think
about it this was self-trained on just
25 images and it was trained for 100 EPO
and on local PC so that's a very very
small set but you can still see that the
potential is there like uh it's not
completely noise uh there are images
where it's almost like 80% good with the
penter one let's say uh and then the
other ones we can do better with more
training it's it has potential so the
next thing we did was create a data
generator script uh and basically we
took the images that we have uh and uh
you know that there could be different
approaches to creating the data uh but
here we decided not to kind uh you know
when you have an image with a background
then you remove the background so that
becomes the training data set we
actually did the other way around so if
we have the pngs with no background we
can add a background to that and use
that as a training set and then uh
programmatically create uh The Masks of
the images that we have transparent so
that is exactly what we did there is
some code uh but basically it was it was
a small script it was not a big effort
so it definitely not perfect but still
it works we also to took a look at the
alpha channels of the image since we
have that information encoded uh to
understand that you know that pngs does
PNG format doesn't mean that the image
will be transparent so we also had to
take take a look for that do other
checks create uh the random backgrounds
either by a random color or we also
gathered a SM set of backgrounds that we
could use in a ratio of the training set
put the those patterns just so it's not
overfitting to just extract the solid
color in the
background so here is the next model
it's very similar to the last one but
the difference here is that we have more
data it is acquired programmatically the
model we use is still the same
so this is this is how it would look
like just to give you an Insight uh so
you see that okay here is the original
image like the the brain would be uh the
original one then the blue would be a
random color that we posted and then
this is the mass that we created so we
feed it to the model and see how it
looks
like all right this is not perfect still
but when you look at it it's getting
better and better in some cases it's
even usable like the last two I'd say I
could use this is great so moving
forward uh the next thing that we did
was we actually thought about the utet
and how it's built so there is an open
source model that is actually
pre-trained for tens of thousands of epo
on a on a large and very researched data
set so it would it seemed very logical
that we utilize the knowledge that the
model can have because we will not be
able to train uh for that large of a
data set for that amount of EPO and have
it be uh computationally and
financially uh great so that is actually
what what we did uh we use the UT UTA
that was pre pre pre-trained on the uh
duts salent object detection data set
which has roughly 11,000 training images
and 5,000 test images and then we find
you with the same set that we used for
just the pure training in the last Model
and uh if you're interested in the
training environment we used it we used
an Amazon sagemaker notebook uh with
accelerated Computing
instance uh yeah so let's look at the
results now this is something I really
like to see you know that these images
already seem something like we can
actually put in a product and have it be
really sellable it it's looking nice
okay maybe there there is a little bit
here and there could where it could be
improved but still you know 100 EPO not
70,000 very big difference uh and you
also might say that uh this is this is
looking very cherry-picked you're
probably just advertising your company
well I'm not advertising my company but
this is kind of cherry-picked we also
had mistakes where it doesn't where it
didn't look so good uh and we looked at
those uh images where something was not
quite working right uh and one
interesting fact that uh there's also
only one example here with the Pug uh
but we actually noticed also that the
lower region of the image was the one
that's causing the most troubles but it
also happened in other places like there
is a missing hand here something is not
quite right there and also the
background is still in the letters
themselves which is not great so our
theory was that uh we can improve this
just by creating a cleaner data set and
uh since the results were leaving to be
desired uh we took a look at the data
set and in the end it really turned out
to be the issue of the data uh one issue
was that if you look at the examples you
can kind of tell that there's a blue
lettering here beyond the rooster but
with the background that it selected
randomly it's not really working there
had to be like I as a human I'm confused
by looking at this so we can only
imagine what the model is thinking uh
same scenario here uh sometimes it even
Blends in completely so when when there
is black on black which is what created
randomly how can a model even learn
anything when the mask is one thing and
then the original is one thing where you
can't really tell anything so uh we
cleaned the data set uh we we cleaned up
those uh with the back with the bad
backgrounds sometimes it was also an
issue of uh not really greatly working
uh backgrounds where they were
uh too large of a pattern and they were
taking over the design you could not
really tell where is the background
where is the foreground so we took out
those took out those where the colors
were blending and we also took out some
images that were not really high quality
uh since we really didn't filter out
those that perhaps are lower resolution
or something so yeah let's see if that
really helped so those are the same
images and now as you can see it it's uh
looking much better uh you can see that
the hand is there you can see that the
tax is no longer blurry and the lower
region of the image is actually looking
looking nicer this is something that we
can move forward with because otherwise
it's it seemed like a
trouble so we proceeded to use this
model with our further experiments and
one more interesting thing that we
needed to uh to research search was the
post-processing of the image uh so there
is this thing called I smoothing uh
maybe I should have put an example of
how it's looking but you can tell here
that uh like the text is not super
greatly uh visible and the edges are not
very smooth but if you apply Alpha
meting uh you can actually refine the
edges uh remove the very remove some
noise that that shouldn't be there and
uh make things just nicer looking so
this is one of the attempts uh this is
with the erosion size one and you can
see that the text now is fully white not
with a black border uh the edges are
looking quite nice and this is
definitely something we can use uh but
you also have to be careful with this
because too much postprocessing would
mean that uh you can remove the details
that you're not actually wanting to
remove like if you have some very fine
text on the design it might get removed
in this process and also we have to take
into account that Alpha matting is a
computational expensive procedure and
the more you do it the more timely it
gets which we do not want we want a fast
response for the
users here is another example also uh
you can see that I do not Advocate you
for you to do it but in some cases where
let's say the foreground was removed a
little bit too much with Alpha meting
it's actually kind of fixing the
mistakes of uh bring bringing out the
foreground but still this is not the
proper way to do it it's just a nice
bonus uh with bigger training sets and a
bigger training time you just have less
of a mistake in the original image that
would be later
postprocessed so the next step that we
did was actually compare the in-house
model with the external one and uh I
have to say already that the judging was
sub the judging was very subjective it
was very Hands-On so uh submitting the
images to the external tools and then
looking at them and seeing which which
one was better just to my eye and and it
was very very non straightforward and
sometimes uh sometimes it was very close
so it's really hard to give it to some
of the things um and uh also one note is
that it was compared against uh free
external tools results so if we say that
external wins it means that actually at
least one of the models got a better
result which is not really fair uh
because it could be one model is better
in one type of image then the other one
is better at the other type of image it
could be very spread apart uh but still
it was very surprising to us that we
managed to match the performance of the
models that have been commercially
available they are trained they are made
to be sold uh and we have a tie in 56%
of the cases I think that's a very good
ratio for us especially when the
training was not uh that comprehensive
it was just a prototype still okay it
was trained more it was more iterative
but not exactly something to be yet prod
productionize and if you look at some of
the examples uh let's say that uh it's a
good one because it has representations
of different types of images so let's
say on text
all of them look quite fine the in-house
ones look fine external fine external
ones look usable so that's great uh then
there are some where it's uh where the
models have different opinions about
what they're seeing so uh on the top one
uh one of the models sees that only the
person should be the foreground this one
is not very great looking to be honest
and ours thinks that the circle in the
middle should be the foreground and as a
human I'm not really sure what I would
do so it's not that I see it as a big
big minus and uh if you see the I'm
image plus text type of image ARS are
actually performing better one of the
models because otherwi other ones got
either the text fully removed or
partially removed which is even worse to
be honest so yeah those are good
results and uh what is happening now
with this project it's uh I say a a
successful Pro proof of concept uh and
now the assessment is being made whether
we can uh uh create something on our own
put it properly in production so what we
need to do is to understand how what
what it cost to host the
service uh what would be the maintenance
effort uh and then we would also need to
do like a proper modeling and periodic
retraining
effort um understand how reliable it is
all of that stuff so before we
understand the before we move to
production we we still need to
understand like is it viable how how
long it would take us how much money
would we need to invest the boring
stuff so what are the takeaways from
this is that external tools are a great
first thing to look at maybe they will
actually be something that you're really
comfortable with so we can use them why
why why invest time if the uh if the
gain over that is not too big
uh then fing open source models with
domain specific data can give good
results as you've already seen um then
one thing that was interesting is that
even if you're using something that
you're find finding online uh you can
you should analyze what you're using
because you might find some offenders
for example one of the case that we did
like that is that we didn't like the
time that we were seeing that it took to
train the model because one app was
train taking a very long time like 3
minutes 4 minutes something like that
and if you understand that you have a
bunch of images and you want to train it
for longer you're going to needs to
decrease the time so what we actually
did we analyzed the training code and we
realized that uh the model was taking in
320 x 320 type uh wide images and it was
doing it on the fly so it was for every
image when it saw in batches it was
still removing again the uh it was still
rescaling again again which T took a
very long time so what we did we created
another script that actually rescaled
the images before we uh started the
training and that was immediately much
much faster it was it was it went down
to 15 20 seconds per epoc and uh with
this there's still room to grow uh you
can get more data you can tune the hyper
parameters which we didn't did because
it was a thing that we we wanted to do
quite fast to ch just to check the
theory that it actually works and uh of
course longer training because still as
I said 100 EPO is nothing compared to
tens of thousands of EPO that these
models are typically trained
on so thank
you uh actually if you are interested we
have we are hiring we have some data nml
model positions so if you really want to
see the code maybe you're interested in
that you can just join us and you'll
gain access immediately so yep thank
you thank you for the presentation um
yeah really uh nice to follow along uh I
especially like the process of uh hey we
need more data let's just make our own
data which is not yeah always the
obvious solution I think uh are there
any questions from the audience probably
a few yeah right here in the
front uh hi so my question is have you
thought about using the smooth out
images as a training data because you
said they improve upon the result of the
model so they can be given to the model
as a better example of what it
did I don't think that's a typically
used approach in uh in this type of task
because uh yeah the mask isn't isn't as
uh smooth as it expect as as you would
expect just to be used uh as a print
file which is very very uh delicate work
I'd say uh it's just like a black and
white map so I'd say that it's something
that should be done uh still after the
fact of the removal but still it's
that's an interesting thought maybe I
will read into this thank
you yeah thanks um I think my question
is partially answered if you also would
use the fusion models because I see an
engineering manager for generative AI
generative M team but would you consider
indeed using for instance uh stable
diffusion models to either generate data
or generate masks have you looked into
that uh I have not I think that uh we
are also using some AI images uh on the
website we have an AI image generator
that Merchants can use and actually
create their own designs with AI so I
think that will be potentially helpful I
think a combo of two approaches so
historical data Maybe stable diffusion
data would be actually nice to kind of
balance it out so yeah
all the way in the
back uh hi um I have a question how do
you deal with transparent objects have
you tried to do it transparent uh like
glass plastic
bottle I don't think I have dealt with
this just because I haven't stumbled
upon some of it perhaps someone would
use an image of a plastic bottle but
don't think it's a common case in our
scenario do you meant like the plastic
or the glass object as a designed right
yes well I think it's similar to a
problem that we had uh let's
say where was it let me prove my point
uh it would be something like like this
so the difference between the back the
background and the foreground which is
the white background very Light Beige uh
text is very difficult for most of the
models so you can kind of extend your
data set with more objects like these
but it's still not 100% guarantee that
it will work well especially if the
difference between the background and
the contents are is very small it's just
the way it is unfortunately yeah I'm
asking you know like taking glass on the
white background and putting on the
black T-shirt or something so it doesn't
sound easy right it's it's
not
thanks any further
questions going once going twice all
right in that case uh thank you very
much for presentation we do have a small
gift on behalf of the organizing
committee um so as not to let you leave
a over empty-handed thek very exclusive
P data a over please give it up for
thank
[Music]
you